[Musique]
le mal cool c'est le gouffre qui menace
à chaque instant d'engloutir le
porte-monnaie de la ménagère pour un
porte-clés on ferait aujourd'hui des
réserves d'épicerie digne d'un long
siège désormais la panoplie de cowboy et
celle de zorro sont détrônés par la
panoplie des porte clés
l'épidémie a atteint en france degré de
virulence certains elle touche en effet
toutes les générations
il suffit pour s'en rendre compte de
jeter un coup d'oeil à la bourse aux
portes clés de la maison de la radio de
5 à 75 ans on suppute on compare on
échange
récemment on a évalué à un million et
demi le nombre des maniaques du
porte-clés mais le bar de monsieur
papillon à paris fut le premier
rendez-vous et reste le temple des vrais
amateurs à vous avez un club et cette
année nous avons déposé les statuts pour
devenir club national malheureusement
non plus à ses grands aplats trouvant le
cas le plus important
le sup happillon et le spécialiste qu'on
consulte aux moments délicats s'y
retrouver aujourd'hui n'est pas 6 1 elle
avait du sens critique et le plastique
nous avait la médaille
vous avez le
les émaux aidé en plastique laver ses
plastiques inondait les deux
sont pas jolis contes pas que l'ex homme
fort du club avec on n'était pas en
collectionne ces plastiques et en plus
en faisant attention encore aux anneaux
alors voici un qui a été trafiquée il
avait cet anneau oui il a beaucoup moins
d'alluré non vous allez aussi les
gadgets
par exemple ces boîtes à musique un
petit marteau un anti américain je suis
papillon sonore de posséder une
collection exceptionnelle de 4000
porte-clés cgt fait mon nom olympia et
distribué aux adeptes du pas saint
pierre celui ci me tenait par phinney
déchets il a les traits rang puisque la
maison qui éditait ces déchets mon
affaire 50 mille francs cette semaine je
garde propagateurs de la passion du
porte clés c'est monsieur papillon qui
lui a donné son nom
c'est le nom que j'ai donné j'ai pris et
je m'occuperai selon votre porte et il y
en en juin 65 répond qu'est philippe aux
populistes
du train où vont les choses il faut
s'attendre à ce que la coop au clae
philly dégénère en clip tôt copeaux clé
mamie
[Musique]